China still isn't held accountable
because remember it was racist to say
that it came from there all right you
had the government the government the
United States government shutting up
professionals Peter McCulla who was the
other guy with the beard the guyt Malone
Robert Malone the guy started MRN and
you're silencing him so when you have
China who I think was behind it and they
did it on purpose not held accountable
the FBI and the government working
together to do yet to do this you have
fouchi who's an Untouchable bureaucrat
rat what's to stop stop them from doing
it again what are you going to do they
nobody got in trouble what is anybody
going to do all we do no all we do is do
this how the hell is fouchi not in jail
how the if you read the book uh the real
Dr fouchi how the f is that piece of
trash not in jail and how is China still
walking around nothing happen